latest on Bud Light here Anheuser-Busch
CEO Michael dorkaris
um addressed delcaris I think we call
him yeah Chris let's call him that uh
address the Bud Light controversy on an
earnings call with investors Thursday
downplaying the Brand's partnership with
transgender influencer Dylan Mulvaney
that prompted a boycott for
conservatives dalkus told investors
there is misinformation spreading on
social media about the company's team up
with Mulvaney we need to clarify the
facts that this was one can one
influencer one post and not a campaign
the CEO said that Anheuser-Busch is
providing direct financial support to
the front line workers impacted by the
boycott naming delivery drivers sale
Representatives wholesalers bar owners
and servers well they're impacted by not
really the boycott so much as Bud Light
and anheuser-busch's own marketing
decisions so this is what this is where
the impact originates
by the way
um Docker said the Brewing giant will
triple media spending on Advertising for
Bud Light over the summer confirming
reports that the company is planning a
major marketing push to recover its
brand
so they're still scrambling here as
sales continue to drop significantly
um across the country but probably the
most significant sign of Bud light's
troubles
that we've seen so far is this video
that somebody posted I think to tick
tock and this is from a Red Sox game
this week and you can see how um busy or
not so busy the Bud Light concession
stand is compared to all the other
concession stands let's see that
guys this is so funny and bizarre look
at that that is the bug Light that is
every single Bud Light stand here
right we're at the Red Sox game
in this time
[Music]
well I guess it's not a bad thing if
you're working the Bud Light stand it
gives you some time to take a nap and
scroll your phone uh that is rough I
mean nobody drinking Bud Light at a
baseball game people are choosing to
wait in longer lines than drink Bud
Light like I've never at any Stadium
I've been to uh you know football
stadium or baseball stadium I I've never
seen that I've never seen like a
massively long line at one stand and
then nobody had another
um
so that that shows you that this is uh
and it's especially terrible at a
stadium because even you know as much as
I hate Bud Light and I hated it before
it was cool to hate it because it's it's
terrible
um even I if there's one place where I
would drink Bud Light up until now it
would be at a stadium
because your your options are limited at
a at a stadium and anyway all beer
tastes better at a stadium at least I
maybe I tell myself that to justify
paying 27 for an eight ounce pour
but either way this is how bad things
are for the company and it's also why I
think
we should probably stop
referring to it as a boycott because
it's it's not even a boycott anymore
it's actually bigger than that and
deeper than that for for Bud Light and a
much bigger problem it's way worse than
a boycott for Bud Light
are we back on well clearly someone in
the control room forgot to turn on
expressvpn expressvpn is an app that
encrypts 100 of my online data to
protect it from cyberpunks like the ones
who tried to terrorize my show today
when I use expressvpn my online presence
is anonymized making it difficult for
anyone to track my online activity and
try to shut me down couldn't be easier
to set up you just tap one button on
your phone or computer and you're
protected expressvpn works on all your
devices your phone tablet computer
wherever you are in the world expressvpn
can and will protect you don't let the
cyberpunks who tried to hijack my show
hijack your information visit
expressvpn.com Walsh get three extra
months for you that's exp r e s s
vpn.com Walsh expressvpn.com Walsh to
learn more
um it is
really a Rebrand
okay and not a Rebrand that Bud Light
wanted
um
it is we we have branded Bud Light this
way based on their own choices
we have branded it this way people
aren't drinking it now not because
they're necessarily consciously trying
to send a statement I think all those
people in line who aren't going over to
the Bud Light stand I'm sure some of
them are thinking this of this as a
boycott and they're sending a political
statement but I think much more it's
just like Bud Light is lame now it's
lame it's not cool
um and your your buddies will make fun
of you if they see you drinking Bud
Light so you're not going to drink it
it has become cemented I think
and
I don't know how they recover from that
I'm not sure how they recover
it's one thing to have a boycott it's
another thing to be branded and they are
branded now this is their brand now
and I'm not sure how you get out of that
the the only way
to do it
would be again to
explicitly apologize
and completely backtrack now they've
already tried to backtrack and I've
tried to say they've issued statements
that do everything but apologize the
only way to maybe shake this branding
off of you
shake the the stink the stench off of
you is to directly apologize
and um
and
to start branding yourself as the
opposite of that
but they're not going to do that because
then they're worried about the reverse
backlash and uh and they don't want to
do that and they figure that's going to
make it even worse for them
um because then it's like well if the
customers are trying to win back if they
still aren't satisfied well it's like
now we've we still have we don't have
them but now we're losing now we have
the left coming after us and so they've
probably figured that they can't do that
uh there's really nothing they can do
this is a
this is how they've been branded
buy their own by their own choices
they've been branded this way
uh
and it's
I keep saying this is this is the I
can't think of another example where
conservatives have been able to achieve
something like this in the fight against
corporate wokism
it it simply is one of the most
significant victories in the fight
against corporate wokism I can't maybe
there have been one that maybe there
have been maybe there's some competition
for the most significant but I'm not
even sure what's competing with it at
this point
which which maybe tells you as much
about the Bud Light thing as it does
about the uh the the parade of failures
by by conservatives up up until now to
land any blows at all against corporate
wokeism but this is a major blow
and I'll tell you something else it is
going to make
brands in the future
think long and hard before
you know promoting transgenderism
there'll still be brands that do it
there can be brands that have a heavily
left-wing customer base they're not
worried about it they're gonna be brands
that figure well they're just they're
they're way too big and powerful uh to
to worry about it so they can do
whatever they want
um I think Bud Light assumed that about
itself it assumed wrong
there may be some Brands where that
actually is true where they could
basically do whatever they want
you know if you're Google or something
you pretty much do whatever you want
um
but there are a lot of other brands that
you know they they would be susceptible
to something like this
they have a heavily conservative or the
United conservative just like an a a
customer base of average middle income
you know normal Americans and they are
going to be very very hesitant
which is a good thing
I'll do it for this Porsche shows move
over members block become a member today
by using Code walls to check out for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you there if not talk to you on
Monday Godspeed